getting back into shape after the
holidays it's usually the most important
number one new year's resolution but
that can be a little tricky during the
pandemic
a lot of the gyms across the valley are
closed or they're only allowing a
limited number of people inside
that's why so many folks are opting to
break a sweat outside in fact
this group here enjoying a game of
racquetball
since most indoor courts are still
closed the beauty of living in las vegas
is that we do have
pretty good weather mostly around for
the most part
anywhere else at in january can you be
playing outdoor racquetball
like this right definitely more outdoor
activities maybe some more hiking
and then just i know it's nice being
able to enjoy the weather
we are lucky here of course working out
at home and online has just
exploded in popularity so we asked you
to name your favorites on our facebook
page
uh responses included everything from a
home gym to online sites such as a
livestrong there's
another one called fitnessblender betty
rocker
others said they simply prefer just
walking around the neighborhood they
don't need any equipment